en parking quelques voitures mais des
panneaux bien visible au slogan choc
traître et une pige traduisez accusé en
référence à l' empêchement est le 25e
amendement de la constitution américaine
après l'envahissement d'un des symboles
de la démocratie à washington par les
supporters de donald trump mercredi les
démocrates n'ont qu'une idée en tête
chaque jour se débarrasser du 45e
président américain au plus vite
quiconque a perdu le contrôle de ses
capacités mentales à ce niveau jusqu'à
déclencher une insurrection contre les
états unis ne devraient pas avoir le
doigt sur le bouton nucléaire et bien
j'aime le 25e amendement parce que ça
nous débarrasse de lui il n'est plus en
fonction mais il ya un fort soutien en
congrès pour mettre en accusation le
président une seconde fois
une deuxième tentative de destitution
franc un an et demi et démocrates ont
déjà d'ailleurs rédigé l'article de mise
en accusation le parlement américain et
ses élus doivent se prononcer sur cette
question dans les prochaines 48 heures
objectif suprême pour le camp démocrate
interdire donald trump d'exercer de
futures fonctions fédérales
fait notable pour cette deuxième
procédure d'impeachment plusieurs grands
élus républicains approuvent
l'initiative
ces derniers indigné par les images du 6
janvier
émeutes qui ont fait cinq morts une
quinzaine de personnes ont été inculpées
à ce jour eh bien je pense que la
meilleure façon pour notre pays et que
le président démissionne et s'en aille
le plus tôt possible
je reconnais que ce n'est peut-être pas
probable mais je pense que ce serait la
meilleure solution et basse
la meilleure chose pour l'unité du pays
ce serait qu'il démissionne
une procédure de destitution qui
s'annonce compliqué juridiquement et
presque irréalisable d'ici le 20 janvier
et l'intronisation du président élu joe
biden
les américains partagés sur la question
on est vraiment proche de la fin de son
administration pour le pays je pense
qu'il serait préférable qu'il part de
son propre chef qu'il démissionne je
crains qu'en fin de compte s'il était
destitué ce serait perçu comme une
punition qui détournerait l'attention
dans le mauvais sens et j'aimerais juste
voir ben hayden montait au créneau et
aller de l'avant
banni des réseaux sociaux twitter
facebook ou encore instagram donald
trump ne compte pas pour autant se
ternir dans le silence jusqu'à son
départ de la maison blanche un
déplacement ce mardi au texas est prévue
avec pour thème l'immigration et la
construction des murs le long de la
frontière avec le mexique